once again when Jerome Powell gets on TV  to make an announcement it's bad news  because he just introduced another three  quarters of a basis points of rates  going up it's going to affect real  estate mortgages auto financing a lot of  different Industries and a lot of people  are panicking today but the truth of the  matter is those who are prepared for  this and those who have the right  strategies have plans of creating  generational wealth so I'm holding a  webinar to talk about how to create  generational wealth and how all these  families we've done so much research on  this topic how to create generational  wealth and more importantly how to keep  it within your family if that's  something that interests you register  for the webinar then click on the link  above or below and I'll see you there's  limited seating so I'll see you on this  webinar